[Music]
you look fantastic
so my beautiful outfit and I will
respect your zone right here right over
there creep looking over at you Jeff guy
in a bow tie on the subway that's
leaning but the bow tie is lovely I mean
do you like the goat I love it I love it
you like the but is it sexy it's very
sexy oh very sexy and and the fact that
you know how to tie it on your own is
incredibly accomplished you look amazing
you look amazing I did this to you I had
poor people help me but I it's we got it
on you always look fantastic
you uh you know everyone's into social
media these days celebrities getting
involved and there's this thing called
throwback Thursdays where people post
pictures of just forget so I do
forgetful Fridays okay well you posted
one you posted a throwback Thursday from
a couple years ago recently and it
exploded my iPhone there you posted this
you true aware that you this was taken
in your backyard
I'm guessing what's going on here
I was gardening nude that was actually
done for a lower magazine that was they
do a section called the nudes and yes I
know that section yeah I go to the store
and ask they're like it's not here yet
come back come back in a week would you
like that photo
oh yes yes do you like that photo thank
you you know whenever I'm around you I
get all crazy I've bumped into you in a
bunch of situations here and there where
it was clear I was following you in your
basement